so good afternoon everyone and thank you
for being here those of you who are
watching remotely thank you for watching
us it's really a privilege to welcome
you to this semester's women of Yale
lecture two years ago we began this
series as a way to showcase the
accomplishments of women who graduated
from Yale with a particular emphasis on
women of color and our guests including
our distinguished speaker today dr.
Patricia Nez henderson represent the
very best that Yale has to offer they
represent the remarkable success of
co-education at Yale which is what we
are leading to celebrating a year from
now it was actually the the idea of my
wife Marta marette who is a woman of
Yale she's a 1984 graduate of our School
of Public Health who proposed the idea
in the context of getting ready for the
celebration of the anniversary of
co-education to have a speaker series
that would bring women of Yelp back to
campus more do you want to wave your
hand the hand around there so as I said
we're approaching the 50th anniversary
of co-education in Yale College that
will be 2019 and each of the events in
this lecture series is a way to honor
the remarkable contributions of our
alumni in 2019 we will have a major
celebration of this milestone and I'm
quite excited about it and I think you
will enjoy it too to be perfectly
accurate though we are not just
celebrating the 50th anniversary of
co-education at Yale we are celebrating
the history of women as students at Yale
that dates back 150 years our art school
was the first to accept women when it
was established in 1869 so we have this
beautiful
symmetry where we celebrate in the same
year 150 years of women at Yale in the
Graduate School and graduate
professional schools and 50 years in
Yale College the journey for women to
gain access to the highest rungs of
higher education has not always been
easy and women of color have faced even
greater barriers so our first speaker in
the series was Maya Lin and as you know
she's the pioneering architect and
artist graduated from Yale College in
1981 earned her master's degree in
architecture in 1986 and came back and
received an honorary degree at Yale some
years later next we welcome Vera wells
who is from the class of 1971 I think
she's here today yes there's Vera who
talked to us she's in the first Yale
College graduating class to include
women but she talked to us about the
first tenured african-american woman on
our faculty last fall we honored Anita
Hill who as you know as a lawyer and a
scholar and a 1980 graduate of our law
school and a pioneer for in her advocacy
for women's rights and really many ways
anticipated the me2 movement years ago
so I guess today is another Yale pioneer
dr. Patricia Nez Henderson she earned
her master's degree in public health
from Yale in 1994 in 2000 she became the
first Native American woman to graduate
from the Yale School of Medicine
she was the inaugural recipient of the
patrician as award at Yale that's a
prize given to graduating medical
student who is committed to improving
the health of American Indians and the
prizes named for her dr. Henderson has
devoted her career to this mission she's
the vice president of the Black Hills
center for American Indian Health she
works very closely with the Plains
tribes to reduce smoking and tobacco use
which as you know is a leading cause of
disease and death
she has grants from the National
Institutes of Health to support this
work she's a member of the US Department
of Health and Human Services interagency
Committee on smoking and health last
year she was awarded the Elias Parker
award for the American Indian science
and engineering society that's an award
given to outstanding Native American
scientists and engineers who've made
great contributions to science or
technology or engineering or math today
I'm very honored to welcome Patricia Nez
Henderson one of the truly outstanding
women of Yale before we get started
though I'm going to encourage you to
write down any questions you might have
for dr. Henderson during this
conversation if you don't have a card
raise your hand and one will be passed
to you or you can just pull out a piece
of notebook paper and after our chat we
will collect the cards from you and we
will try to answer as many of them as we
can so before we get to Q&A we're going
to have a fire without the fire in a
building that houses great works of art
you probably don't want too many
fireplaces but welcome again thank you
all for coming
welcome again dr. Henderson so let's
start with the beginning of your time at
Yale what what brought you to the yell
of School of Public Health sure I had
just completed my my degree in
biochemistry from University of Arizona
when I actually wanted to strengthen my
medical school application and decided
to apply to one of the schools one of
the top schools of public health and it
was Yale recruit it actually had come
out to Tucson looking for students and I
applied and I got in and so that began
my journey to to this beautiful campus
what did you emphasize when you were
studying public health um health policy
and resources right still we still have
health policy administration section of
our public health school yeah and then
then you went home but then you came
back for medical school right well
actually yeah I mean I had decided at
that time that I wanted to continue to
pursue my my lifetime goal of becoming a
doctor and I applied to a couple of
medical schools and I got accepted to
two of them and it was Yale and Stanford
so I was actually they invited me to
Stanford to look at the campus and I was
greeted by a group of Native students
that were that were in medical school
and they courted me gave me a wonderful
meal and told me just how wonderful my
experience would be there at Stanford
but it was actually it was a great visit
and I was flying back into New Haven and
it just something just pulled at me I
was like I need to stay here and that
began my journey in the School of
Medicine Wow so you told me a story on
the phone we were talking a few weeks
ago planning this interaction about
being being in the School of Medicine
and thinking that maybe you should drop
out and go home what was that all about
and then what convinced you to carry on
well for any of you that are in the
School of Medicine that are medical
students or even residents medicine is
tough let alone just with everything
else that you have to do if you're a
parent and you have children you know
you're having to make that balance for
me it was just I was going through
something very very traumatic for me my
whole Navajo community on now who nation
actually was being forcefully relocated
and it was very difficult for me to kind
of process that and then having to deal
with step one step two of medical school
right
so it was hard and I never really talked
about that experience with anybody and
probably I should have maybe it would
have made my experience a little bit a
little bit more bearable and getting the
resources that I needed so I could deal
with that trauma and then deal with
being in med school so was in my second
year I just I just I explained that
situation as my heart was being severed
from my head and I went to Association
of American Indian Science and
Engineering Society and met the late
chairman of the Cherokee tribe Wilma
Mankiller and I was like just in tears
you know I was just like I'm ready to
quit
I just can't take this anymore and she's
like are you done crying like are you
done crying just like as Patricia she's
like you have to stay at Yale if it's
not for you do it for the future
patrician is that are going to be coming
from Navajo Nation or other reservations
that are you know that have their eye on
Yale and so I came back and I was like
okay I can do this and just started
bringing more of the faculty I guess
Yale faculty into my inner circle
because up to that point I was just very
closed off and and it really made a big
difference to get to you you grew up on
the reservation and to get to Yale for
public health school and then for
medical school that must have been a bit
of a journey too did you know that were
there others who came before you that
set an example of course my grandfather
was a traditional healer so he had
multiple degrees I believe and I always
say he's one of the smartest men I've
known so I come from a long long line of
healers both on my mom and dad's side
and so I saw medicine in a holistic way
during during that time period
and so when I came to Yale especially in
med school I just
it was very focused on allopathic
medicine so in our history of medicine
oh there's a couple people in that class
we were always raising her hand and
challenging the system like you know
there's other forms of medicine and
let's not just exclude them let's talk
about it and during that time they
called it alternative medicine you know
and and even NIH called it you know that
I think they called it complementary yes
so so yeah so then after that I think
the next class that came through they
were able to have a class for them where
they could explore other forms of med
are the forms of healing so that was
that was nice
was there was there how in general how
open would you say Yelp public health
school Public Health Yale School of
Medicine were to looking at things in a
in an alternative way or the
complementary way did you get a lot of
pushback or were you able to I think it
was during that time period when people
were becoming a little bit more open to
chiropractic care to elip know to you
know
Ayurvedic medicine traditional medicine
you know even with the Indian Health
Service they were beginning to explore
how we can bring traditional healers
into the healthcare system so I came in
right at that peak and or at that
beginning of that journey and and I
think I'm hoping now that you know the
School of Medicine is probably I can
think of a there are a lot more open
towards other forms of healing so yeah
it was challenging but we we got through
it or I got through it well let's talk
about a little bit about fast-forward to
to the present talk a little bit about
how you got from Yale to the kinds of
work you now do obviously it was your
cultural backgrounds where you
grow up but you made a decision at some
point to work on native health issues
and how'd you make that decision sure it
was actually in my second year of med
school after I had finally passed step
one and I began to kind of just have
this conversation with myself about
Indian health care about the health of
native populations and I really really
enjoyed my time at the School of Public
Health and I love that approach about
about enhancing wellness and I was like
how do I do that how do I you know use
my my my degree in medicine and do the
do work in public health so I had an
advisor at the School of School of
Public Health that really kind of guided
me on how I could do that so by my third
year when rotation started I kind of had
a good idea like yeah I'm just gonna get
my degree and and move forward and not
do residency so it was a tough decision
because like all my life since probably
like 3 years old I've always wanted to
be a physician like that was my goal and
then for that to kind of begin to morph
into something different is what's a
little bit challenging but I just really
really wanted to do something that was
would drive you know I guess I would do
something that would bring passion into
my life and continue to work so at the
end I decided to move to South Dakota
not just for any reason actually my
husband is from South Dakota he's Lakota
Sioux from the Cheyenne River Sioux
tribe and he was just in the midst of
forming a non-profit organization and so
we just joined him I jumped right in and
began to kind of explore what I could do
in the in the realm of Public Health
is there you know we have a growing
native student body here at yellow I
know in Yale College we were about 1%
Native American just a few years ago now
we're up to 3% it's not these aren't
huge numbers but but that is a that's
growth in the right direction
and we have wonderful Native American
Cultural Center and Association of
Native Americans here at Yale and in
would you give their is their advice you
would give them about as they make
choices between you might say a more
typical career versus a traditional
career going home not going home
may be its unique a unique decision for
each person but what advice would you
give that oh absolutely I think first
and foremost you know our you know I
just go back to my own experience that
150 years ago my great-great grandmother
and my great-great grandfather actually
were released from from an encampment at
once day they would say in the Navajo
language and it's the long walk when
thousands of tribe tribal Navajo tribal
members were held against her will and
they were released in 1900 and 50 years
ago so everything that I do from here on
out is to respect that like they made a
huge sacrifice and I think a lot of
Native students that are in this room
probably have had that same experience
like our ancestors really paid the price
for us and so do things to honor them
you know whether it's a career in art
you know focusing on British art or
whatever or going back to the
reservation and being a schoolteacher
whatever it is it's just honor honor
that legacy and
and if it involves tribal communities
that's wonderful if not that's fine and
I think for me it's just been like I
always knew deep down like I want it to
work with tribal communities there is a
park I think and like my fourth year
it's like well maybe I can be an ear
surgery nor a plastic surgeon and work
in Beverly Hills you know but at the end
I was like no I want to go back I want
to work with tribes and it's just been
one of the most fulfilling fulfilling
times of my life so a lot of your work
focuses on smoking and smoking cessation
you tell us a little bit about that that
journey yeah absolutely so after annal
fel I actually joined the faculty at
University of Colorado and during that
time one of my primary mentors was
looking for individuals that could do
work among tribal communities in a more
sensitive way because we all know about
helicopter fact right people coming in
into a community and then taking data
and then never sharing that back with
tribe or with any community well my
mentor and his wife was like no we don't
want that we want to really bring up a
culture of bring up a cohort of Native
investigators that can really understand
that understand the communities already
and their needs and work with tribes in
a way where it's respectful and being
have them be included in in the process
of research so they asked they asked me
like what are you interested and I was
like cancer I think you know cancer is
just very you know it's a it's an area
that needs a lot of work and they're
like well you live in South Dakota it's
like why not smoke you know it's like oh
you know what smoking is just not that
sexy it's like but they're like there's
high rates I'm like yeah you know all
right fine
let me let me do a second air start you
know I started off with the secondary
data analysis that got published and I
was like oh my goodness wow this is
actually very interesting and and we got
one of our first grants and actually was
with the Navajo name
and I went back to the tribe and it was
from CDC and and I went back to a group
of people that I knew knew all the
answers and it was with the true healing
a traditional healing society and it was
a room of men primarily men I asked them
in Navajo it's like how many of you
actually use cigarettes in your
ceremonies coming you know after living
in South Dakota for like 15 years I
thought oh that's not gonna be that many
you know Navajo Nation doesn't have that
that same problem that other tribes have
and literally more than 75 percent of
the population are 70 percent 75 percent
of the men that are in that room raised
their hand saying that they use they use
cigarettes in their ceremonies and I was
like literally floored so yeah I said to
them in Navajo I said you know
regardless of how you use it
meaning the cigarette I said you take it
in it will not only hurt you but it's
gonna hurt everybody around you and that
began that began my journey into you
know really incorporating the
traditional I guess values of commercial
us not only commercial tobacco but
ceremonial tobacco in my work so it's
been it's been wonderful so I had there
been an evolution in in the cultural
traditions from using tobacco as a
sacred plant and and that became the use
of cigarettes over time is that what
happened absolutely
back in the late 1800s or is actually
laws that were passed by the federal
government to prohibit native tribes and
communities from practicing their
ceremonies so they were using certain
plants to have you know to get during
their ceremonies but because it was now
outlawed it was probably just I'm
thinking it was probably just a little
bit easier to have a cigarette there and
use it during their ceremonies because
they actually had Scouts there were
native Scouts within the community that
work for the federal
so any time you had a chant or the only
time there was other types of ceremonies
you know these people were there so it's
just easy to pick up that cigarette and
say oh I'm just casually smoking I'm not
using it for ceremonies or whatever you
know so so it was a way of avoiding
absolutely [ __ ] ceremonial right so I
mean it's kind of ironic right there
smoking a cigarette would be fine but
using tobacco in a traditional ceremony
would be outlawed right exactly
so now that the environment many my
reservations are is that children start
smoking at a very young age we have an
early age of initiation and not only
that both men and women smoke at high
rates particularly among the Northern
Plains tribes so over the past you know
18 years I was 20 years now can I've
been really focused on providing
education to these communities in a
respectful way where that tribal
leadership in can begin to better
understand the importance of policy for
example and cessation because what's the
station we just know very very little we
know that the native tribes act native
people who smoke actually smoke less
cigarettes per day than the general
population so there's you know they're
metabolizing cigarettes very differently
than other populations we just did a
study recently looking at looking at the
genetic component of that and better
understanding you know how to how to
work with tribes in in terms of
cessation is there a particular so I've
always been interested in health
communication myself I'm a psychologist
and worked a lot in the health area one
of the things we noticed in in our work
was when we were just working with
adolescents here in New Haven and you
asked them what kind of a message would
keep you from smoking cigarettes they
always say well you know
you know if you frightened me and a few
if I show me that black one or you know
you know we get them to design a
billboard first man they don't sign
things with usually something kind of
disgusting and a skull and crossbones
and all that and it turns out those
messages actually have no plot no impact
on the very people who think that those
are going to be the best way to to
motivate them not to smoke and actually
here in Haven our work was on positive
messages about you know how you'll feel
if you don't smoke right so you know
you'll run faster you'll jump higher
people will like you better you'll smell
better you know all as opposed to you
will you will die of lung cancer or and
it was far more effective all this
positive kind of thing and we could tie
it with being you know being more
appealing as a teenager to others and
you know there people beginning to date
what have you and that this would you
know this would make them more appealing
as opposed to looking cooler or as
opposed to whatever dot dying young so I
wonder you know in that that experience
kind of taught me that my intuitions
were completely wrong about what kinds
of messages would be effective to get
people not to smoke and even asking the
people what who were targeted by these
messages what kind of messages would get
you not to smoke their intuitions were
wrong too and something else is what
worked and so I'm just curious what what
works in in the communities that you
have been studying yeah that's a loaded
question but I think it's a it's a blend
of everything all used to Navajo the
Navajo community as an example when we
first started MIT providing education to
the Navajo tribe you know a group of
individuals we got together said oh
let's let's call it Villa Ghana Veneto
and lagana but not talk about that alone
if you literally translated that Sam
it means white man's tobacco well in it
well not only heard the inner you know
the inner essence of who you are but
everything around you well we went with
that right white man's tobacco will hurt
you and then one of our Navajo code
talkers former chairman of the Navajo
Nation Peter McDonald says to us well I
just have a problem with that he says
and all this time we've been running ads
right saying this and he's like I just
have a problem with this what about
cigarettes from other countries like
China and Turkey he was like I really
don't like you just focusing on white
people I was like oh so we ended up we
ended up he ended up coining a different
way to describe cigarettes he said why
don't you call it the the cigarette that
are the not Boneta for the enemies
cigarette the enemies tobacco so we've
gone that route so so yeah I think you
you you have to do a lot of qualitative
work doing focus groups and key to
Informer key informant interviews and
better understanding what messages will
resonate not only with the elders but
all the way down with the youth and it
has to be repetitive you know right now
we're of course tribal communities have
casinos and a very very small percentage
of the 400-plus casinos that have been
established here in the US less than 15
of them actually are smoke-free
completely smoke-free not just a little
tiny area in the back being a
non-smoking section I'm talking about
the whole the whole place so it's now
we're dealing with not only the gaming
you know executives but elected the
leaders what kind of messaging will work
for them to better understand like
secondhand exposure and smoke exposure
any amount even just a whiff well you
know well impact your life so that's
what we're doing we're doing economic
data analyses of casinos that have gone
smoke-free looking at their revenues and
using that as a teaching you know tool
to to better educate tribal leaders like
your earlier comments about the messages
remind me of research that's been done
not in our lab but we're tapping into
adolescent rebellion and in particular
kind of political politically charged
message about you know fight fight the
power right don't smoke corporate
cigarettes right don't this is what
corporate America wants you to buy and
they want to hook you on this product
and they want your money and they're
gonna take your money for and it
actually was pretty effective I'm not
gonna I'm not going to support that you
know and it kind of worked and again you
know your comments remind I think all of
us have the importance of finding out
what really drives people before we
think we know what what those effective
message yeah absolutely
that the tobacco industry has preyed on
Indian communities for a long time the
data shows that you look into you know
the documents that industry documents
and tribal the word tribal sovereignty
is in there the word of lower price you
know cigarettes like they've done so
much research on tribal communities and
so now you you go on to tribal
reservation and you see lower lower
costs for cigarettes for example so an
advertisement very huge so yeah I mean
there's still where the state was
probably 20-30 years ago it's where the
tribe is right now I remember driving
from here to Cranston street and seeing
13 tobacco related advertisement so that
was what 20 20 years ago
we still have a lot of work to do in
Indian country but I think with the
right resources and trained individuals
and Public Health that are willing to
work in this area we certainly can yeah
make a difference if could the tribes
have their own tax to cigarettes sold on
the reservation and that's one thing
that we're advocating for tribes to do
is increase taxes on tobacco products
without even approval from this state
tribes are sovereign they can do
whatever they want inspecting and and
then those revenues can come directly
back to the tribe and bill better
infrastructures for health or creating
smoking cessation programs that are
appropriate for their community so
there's a lot that the tribe can do yeah
so what are the other health issues that
you're working with back back at home
and or but you know I I would say in
Native communities most more generally
and so I just recently started doing
some work in suicide prevention they're
in rapid they're in South Dakota we have
one of the highest rates of suicide
completion in the world so the small
community in South Dakota has
unfortunately has that record of the
number of suicides that are completed by
by youth and by adults in and we know
very little in terms of treatment like
how do we intervene where do we
intervene not only that but we're
talking you know then there's two
treatment options
what treatment options what treatment
plans are are more effective for this
community and then you know you come to
any community on the South Dakota and
and any place actually probably across
Indian country there's lack of
psychiatrists therapists so there's a
huge need so we've been working with a
foundation the American American
Foundation for Suicide Prevention over
the last year and a half and they've
given us a little bit of seed money to
to develop brochures culturally
appropriate for sure
brochures and just mention messaging as
you're talking about to kind of began to
have this dialogue with tribal nations
about how to address this very important
public health issue the higher rate of
completion what do we think that's due
to a whole slew of factors including
poverty you know unfortunately that's
very high in our many of our communities
leading to you know depression of course
but I think we still don't know too much
about it you know there's been very very
little work that has been done in this
area particularly with you and I think
it's an area that I'm very becoming more
and more compassionate about as as we
move forward so in ten years when you
and I sit here you can ask me all about
it so tell us tell us a little bit more
about the center the center that you and
your husband built and what is its
mission absolutely the black health
center for American Indian Health was
founded in 1988 and the overall mission
is to enhance the wellness of tribes
tribal communities and individuals
through research education and service
and ultimately philanthropy so and we've
been doing this work my husband is an
internist by training and got his
master's in public health and he was
very passionate about this because he
he's practiced he practiced as a
physician on one of the Sioux tribes and
just felt like public health is needed
we a lot of these things that are
happening among our tribes can be
prevented through and so he started this
organization and and I kind of just
followed him and we've been doing this
together for great like I said for 18
years and it's just been one of the now
20 years is that you yeah 20 years I'm
sorry
it's been it's a wonderful you know
wonderful
operation that we have
of course we've been courted I mean
we've been so successful we've been
courted by universities to join their
faculty but there was just one recently
just a couple of months ago and we
turned it down we feel like that we have
a very very special relationship with
the tribes and and we want to keep it
that way I think that's very important
for both of us so he really focuses on
on diabetes as an internist of course
diabetes cancer and now he's diving into
social justice and how how all that
impacts health outcomes yeah so we have
I think whether you have college
students students from the public health
school students from the medical school
and and maybe beyond and I think you've
given nice examples of how we can export
some of the things that are learned here
at Yale back to communities like the one
you live in in South Dakota but what
about the other direction
what can what can we learned here at
Yale and the way we do things in the way
we teach and what our students are
learning in the classroom from watching
what you are doing in South Dakota and
from studying the communities that you
serve I think for most importantly for
most importantly is to have tribes be a
part of your discussions in your class
it's very very important I found this
out during my time here is a lot of
people come to yell from diverse
communities and a lot of them
unfortunately don't know the history of
American Indians and Alaska Natives so
there's a lot to be taught I was just
touring the art thing you know on this
both on the second and third floor and
I'm looking for like okay this is the
British Art Museum and I know that the
British community interacted with tribes
but I didn't really see that as an
example so
so I think it's you know we have this
wonderful opportunity we have these
beautiful tribal communities here at
here in New Haven
not in here New Haven but here in
Connecticut great resource you know how
many people know the history of the
Mohicans are the Pequot tribe you know
my daughter's Alaniz here with me and
she was she and I were just reading she
was reading to me as we were driving in
talking about the Narragansett tribe and
how they had a roll in and pay me the
history here I think it's just going out
there and then or them coming here and
having having dialogue and continue that
that dialogue is really important the
issue of representation with your the
art example is really one we struggle
with actually I had in my office four
years of Remington painting of native
man look at to me it always looks like
he was standing on the edge of the Grand
Canyon could look like the end of a long
and people used to comment on that
painting all the time first it the way
he was represented but also at the title
that Remington gave to this painting
which is shocking when you hear it I'll
tell you what it is but it's only the
painting that Remington gave this
painting was the last of his race right
and I I had it in my office for a long
time because I wanted people see that
title and I wanted to have a
conversation about it but it became too
shocking actually you could just be just
it was really upsetting I think for
people to see a title of a painting like
that independent of the way the man was
depicted in that painting and so we
struggle we struggle with that that kind
of a question on campuses all the time
what's them how do you celebrate how do
you educate how do you not appropriate
how to honor
right it's they're not easy questions
absolutely and I you know honor is a big
part of our our tradition you know
whether it's honoring our past
you know our ancestors or and honoring
ourselves but also honoring this
we called the seventh-generation so like
seven different generations from now
who's gonna be out there you know my
granddaughter my great-great-great
granddaughter you know what kind of
experience is she gonna have and well
our tribe would still be a tribe you
know our actually I I think people
probably don't know this but American
Indians have a different citizenship
then non-natives so with the strike of a
pen
our president could totally deny us our
citizenship so I think just
understanding that history and
incorporate that into an institution
like this and educating people is very
important as we move forward before we
turn to your questions I have a feeling
that there are people here who are
interested in working on Native American
health issues or with Native community
communities more generally and how can
how can people here y'all get involved
either while they're students or after
they graduate absolutely there's many
opportunities if you're interested in
working tribal communities
first of all contact the tribe
we have over 566 federally recognized
tribes and a couple hundred of state
recognized tribes they're always looking
for people whether it's volunteering at
the school or you know just picking up
trash on the rez or finding a more
humane way to deal with the rez dogs you
know whatever it is there's a lot of
work that can be done on tribal lands
and tribal communities but also majority
of us actually live in urban settings
about you know so it's not just tribal
communities but urban settings that
where there's urban health clinics
there's there's a lot of ways that they
can do that and for us we welcome the
Black Hills Center for American Indian
Health welcome students matching meeting
with one of the students tomorrow to
talk about her interest
interpersonal violence among the Native
women so and we're gonna be hopefully I
think she's an undergrad here so Yelp
probably give her a little bit of seed
buddy and she can come in live we'll set
up a teepee for her in Rapid City and
buffalo hide and welcome hers exactly
just we're totally open to two graduate
students we have a lot of data sets that
need to be analyzed so there's a lot of
opportunities absolutely
so students at Yale are often very
motivated by wanting to engage in lives
of service to others wanting to take
their education and give back in some
ways we talk a lot about the the the
script that I read when we give degrees
at graduation doesn't say I
here's your degree I admit you to all of
its rights and privileges it's not the
languages we say I admit you to all
their rights and responsibilities and I
think our students are always taken that
very very seriously but it's hard to
make a difference in the world often the
world seems to carry on in its own pace
and with its own challenges that are not
in our control hot well what would you
say to students to encourage them to
lead the lives of service that they that
they really imagine for themselves I
think the most important gift that we
can give others is of our time you know
and certainly being here at Yale you've
had the opportunity to be schooled by
some of the world-famous faculty and and
that's a gift and now you pass that on
you have to you have to share that with
others you know and I always tell that
to my daughter I said you you know
service is so important whether it's
just helping out
for example she volunteers with our
Center either doing that or
or just helping you know single moms
back on the reservation wherever it is
it's very very very important to give
back I really believe that and you know
through many wonderful acts of people
here at Yale
you know I I've learned that actually
over that my lifetime but it was
reinforced while I was here and one
person that is here oh okay
some faculty from the School of Medicine
and School of Public Health are here and
they really teach that and and with the
now it really incorporates that into the
nappa philosophy of giving as well and
just being you know and do it with a
good heart otherwise you're gonna
totally miss the meaning behind giving
that's what a fall advice may be with
that I'll turn to the questions that
people have submitted we do you have we
will not get to all of them I'm afraid
maybe I spoke too long but okay great so
what stakeholders are engaged with
reducing smoker smoking like schools or
community centers or or other agencies
and are there partnerships you are
looking to establish in the future with
agencies that you don't currently work
with absolutely to address you know the
high rates of smoking among our
population we need everybody at the
table and all look you know from the
federal level to the state level to non
non profit organizations and on the
Navajo Nation we and we started a
coalition and we reached out to CDC we
read well that's you to see cuts to CDC
was there already but for American
Cancer Society they're like well can we
actually come onto your reservation
looks like of course you can it's like
and a lot of people actually a lot of
people think that they need passed
words to come on to tribal community
they don't know that they can just come
across and sit with us at the table
so yeah I mean and and then of course
funding agencies are really really
critical and then the involvement of of
traditional healers I cannot express
that enough to address tobacco control
effectively we need them at the table we
need the youth we need the elected
leaders but I think the work with the
work that we've done you know throughout
Indian country it's it's having the
traditional healers they know the
history you know how to do this
correctly and they're like the pastors
of the non of the non-native communities
right are the you know and they're the
ones that are going to lead us and
provide us guidance as we move forward
so this is a question from a yell senior
who I'm suspecting as a pre-med because
he he says what you know what is it you
actually like about being a physician
and and I would add to that and maybe
you want to explain a little more your
decision to become public health
physician and work in the community
rather than do a residency and going in
a more traditional I traditionals by the
one word in this context but a more
typical pathway yeah I think working
with we as a physician you can still
work with communities and work with
individuals in treating that patient but
I chose to to focus on the community at
large and whether it's at the local
level the regional level level or the
federal level and that's just been very
fulfilling for me and to really for
example to really explain to NIH for
example the National Cancer Institute
the history of how
tribes got higher rates of smoking than
any other population we have to go back
to the federal government policies that
were put in place
and and talk about that openly like the
role of the government being involved in
that and when we did that actually when
I did then have that conversation with
this one person she just was like in
tears she's like I never heard this you
know I'm never so yeah so to do work in
public health is quite amazing and I
would really really encourage for anyone
that's interested in medicine to take a
year off and do work in public health or
get your degree in public health open up
your eyes to a whole new area which is
really awesome
if this is inspiring anybody who's here
the Dean of public health was sitting
right talk to him afterwards so this is
a question from a public health student
in the mph class of 2019 and she said my
question surrounds the continued
segregation in the US and systemic
disparities on reservations how do many
of us as outsiders to tribal communities
help address real issues such as tobacco
use while also being respectful and
culturally humble and allowing community
resources to be the solution in other
words how can how can a non-native
professionals actually offer help in a
respectful way oh goodness that home
that's ridiculous yeah and that is a
very very big question I think what I
would recommend to this person or
anybody in this room is again coming out
to the tribal community coming to for
visit I think you will not understand
the depth of need until you actually go
out there there's you can get to see the
schools the government in many many
communities high rates of poverty and
and you will get pulled some things can
pull you in and you'll understand like
this is where where I can help
if you have a lot of money donating to
organizations like us will help of
course but there's such a huge need
contacting your your senators you know
very easy thing to do
letting them know that there's a
disparities between what our need is in
addressing health disparities in Native
communities versus what the government
gives us so just being an advocate I
guess is what I'm asking folks to do
just really being out there and asking
for folks for our federal government to
to do its job correctly yeah this is a
question also from a student doesn't say
in what school but as someone in
medicine do you find yourself sometimes
having to negotiate facts about health
with cultural traditions and cultural
beliefs and you know do you get pushback
occasionally when ideas that you have
from Western medicine are in conflict
with cultural traditions and what do you
do if people the phrase this person uses
as deny a health fact that now is well
validated empirically because it flies
in the face of a cultural tradition how
do you handle that that is a really good
question I'll just use an example this
example when we were working with the
Navajo Nation to pass a policy to
prohibit smoking in all public places in
workplaces I was asked by a leader so
dr. Henderson are you saying that if I
smoke this cigarette inside this teepee
where the ceremony was being held and I
had a pregnant woman sitting next to me
that that the smoke from the cigarette
it would actually be inhaled by by that
woman and that it would impact the fetus
I was like yes at that moment I thought
oh my goodness this elected leader
actually understands this the impact of
secondhand smoke well he voted a
different way he he continued to promote
secondhand smoke exposure so I think you
just have to be I guess be patient with
tribal leadership I mean it took how
many years for the state of Connecticut
to finally pass a smoke-free policy I
mean despite knowing all the facts right
it took many many years and we're just
now in the environment in our
communities where that's the case and
now we're dealing with these cigarettes
and jewels and everything all these new
products are coming up we know very
little about it but we know that the
exposure of it's probably not good and
it's addictive so it just takes a lot of
Education a lot of patience so keep at
it as you keep at it so from a public
health perspective this is also a
student from a public health perspective
can indigenous cultural and political
Canon indigenous cultural and political
resurgence improve indigenous peoples
health in other words does empowerment
lead to the adoption of better health
practices and better health outcomes
absolutely they go ahead you know
they're certainly like I said they're
certainly that that time to to educate
these individuals but within time it's
gonna happen so yes so this is a
personal question I hope you're okay
with it this was faculty member who
submitted this one and it starts with
the observation that you work every day
with your husband and there must be both
joys and tensions
involved in a yeah nobody asked you
Martin the of working everyday with your
husband and as well as raising kids
being a working mother it's a try you
want to comment on that is it is it a
joy or is it an extra challenge my
husband is just dr. Jeff Anderson it's
just one of the most amazing man I have
met
that's what have been Marta's answer to
I just have to always think about that
when I say something about my husband
but seriously he's just like if he ever
met doctor and if you ever met my
husband's Alaniz dad you would say that
he's just very very passionate about the
work he does in Indian country very
vocal and he's been so supportive of the
work that I've done in tobacco control
up to this point in any work that I've
done and while his office is actually
next to mine we're just so focused on
the work that we're doing individually
that our interactions are actually a
little bit limited you know and we get
home or like oh how was your day didn't
see you all day well he was actually
next door to me because we have our own
sets you know we have our own teams and
we're just so busy doing that so it's
worked out really really well
I you know I just don't have any
complaints about their complaints we
only have about ten minutes so I'm gonna
try to get to as many of these as I can
but I apologize in events if I don't get
to your question so this is an
interesting one
you're a Navajo woman you're working in
South Dakota did you encounter
challenges there working with different
tribes than your own background and how
did you build relationships in South
Dakota that Sally good question so the
Navajo Nation the people themselves are
maitre lineal
so the Sioux tribes are Pedro lineal so
when I married my husband we I just put
my foot down I said to him and it
started there I put my foot down I said
our children are gonna be enrolled in
the Navajo Nation no questions
we're just no no no discussions it's it
put my foot down mm-hmm and I said that
they can have a look Kota name so
Holliday has a Lakota name and so that's
how that was my introduction to the
Lakota culture right so I just have to
be assertive no but yeah so so my
approach to working with Lakota tribes
is very different from the Navajo Nation
with the Navajo Nation I can speak my
voice as a woman be hard in addressing
the leaders because that's the role of a
Navajo woman they're very forceful and
strong if there's any Navajo women and
here you know this and I can do that
comfortably whereas with the Lakota
people I kind of have to be a little bit
more reserved because first of all it's
not my tribe it's my daughter's tribe my
husband should try but I just know where
my role is and what I can say in can't
see and I do it more more reserved not
not so forceful yeah so that's probably
the big difference and because I'm so
passionate about the work I do sometimes
it can kind of come off a little strong
so I have to be really really careful
about that especially with secondhand
smoke exposure so so in psychology
there's this idea of emotional labor
when you have to regulate your behavior
like that yeah is it is it app siren you
know absolutely absolutely and you have
to do that in other ways people will
push you away and and there's so much
work that needs to be done with the
Lakota people and other tribes in the
Northern Plains as it comes to
addressing tobacco yeah I I have to know
where my role is
what my role is so this is a question
from a native student here at Yale in
the class of 2020 what advice can you
give Native students at Yale who are
battling with Yale for course credit or
recognition for the teaching and
learning of native languages so is there
any advice about how to transcend Yale's
more Eurocentric approach probably to
everything but certainly to the teaching
of languages question you the President
and I can have breakfast tomorrow I
really so what about opportunities this
is from a staff member who's here
opportunities for Native American women
and girls do you feel that they've
improved since the time when you were
young is there more of an acceptance of
a greater range of opportunities and
roles that that Native women can oh
absolutely you can see that through all
spectrums of I guess disciplines there's
you know particularly in medicine as you
know we know now that you know what 20
18 years ago 20 years ago and I
matriculated as one of the one of few
Native students and the first American
anyone to graduate from Yale now we have
multiple of women that have come after
me and so it's wonderful it's really
nice to see that but I truly believe
there's still there's still more more
more more of a need to to get more
students here of color particularly
those of American in Alaska Native
Heritage and as as the former president
of the Navajo Nation once said in a
lecture here at Yale it's wonderful that
you
you know we welcoming you he's speaking
to Yale faculty it's wonderful that you
know we welcome you to come on to our
reservation to our tribal communities to
recruit Native students but when do you
come when they come here treat them well
and I think that's very important when
they do come here treat them well and
it's really wonderful to see the native
house that has been built for for that
you know for the students here we have
yell faculty but it doesn't match up to
you know what it should be you know
there's I'm not sure how many yell
faculty women that are native that are
here
I'm very small in years one at zero are
we at zero right now we might be yeah so
in School of Medicine for example I
would like to know how many women Native
people are faculty there because until
these students can see themselves and
look at a doctor and say oh my goodness
she's she's uh she's on faculty at the
School of Medicine I can be that person
yeah it's very challenging to see
yourself there so you and I have a lot
of work to do no doubt I think those of
you who are following news here in New
Haven you've seen recent examples of
this there's an addiction crisis in our
country we are not immune from it here
in New Haven and it's been spotlighted
in the media quite a bit lately is there
anything that we've learned from
treating addiction in Native communities
that might transfer to the larger
addiction problem that we're seeing in
the country right now
places like that is a very very good
question a lot of practices actually
traditional practices that were
performed by traditional healing
practices that were performed by our
traditional healers have been used to
address mental illness
we don't know too much about you know
how that can be you know can be used in
other populations because we've been so
closed about our traditional healing
practices because of the policies that
were put in place to get rid of them
right so I think there's there's that
room to better understand how we can use
some of those modalities to church to
treat addiction in other populations do
you see in general this is also a
question but it seems to follow on this
one do you see in general a movement
from mainstream medicine toward a more
holistic approach that might reflect
Native American healing practices and
approaches to whether it's addiction or
psychiatric issues or general medical
issues absolutely goodness yes there's
certainly a lot of room for improvement
in our in our hospitals you know we have
priests it'd be wonderful to see
traditional healers there for people
that want to use them I know that on
many of the hospitals and clinics on
tribal lands they've incorporated that
and and the the patients are happy with
that
they have that option to to go next door
to the hospital where there's a whole
gone and have a ceremony done for them
so that's really nice and it's paid for
you know the traditional healers get
paid you know not by like in in previous
history like by horses or cattle but
they actually get monetary payment so
that's really nice let me end with a
question that's might be a little more
political October as a month that
includes indigenous peoples day we have
particularly you could say challenging
situation here in New Haven the
italian-american community loves
Columbus Day
digitus people and those who understand
what that means for them asked us invite
us to celebrate it as indigenous peoples
they how do we
what's the respectful thing that that we
all can be thinking about and doing as
this time of the calendar rolls around
for those of you that worked here 25
years ago and saw that statue of Tom of
Christopher Columbus all in toilet paper
that was not me Wow
well I will ask I guess the question is
like whose homeland are you on you know
most of us most of us are visitors to
this land whether you came you know on
boats or whether you cane against your
will you came here to our country and I
think it's time for United States to
recognize that and and for our tribes to
finally stand up and and they are
standing up for our rights the country
of Canada New Zealand and Australia have
done tremendous work in reconciliation
and really acknowledging the role of
First Nations and other indigenous
tribes throughout the world about their
homeland and you know there's very few
of us we represent less than 1% of the
population here in the United States but
we're still here you know and I think
New Haven needs to acknowledge that you
know I respect my brothers that are
Italian and and my sisters that are
Italian that
this is our homeland and let's celebrate
it in a way that acknowledges and raises
you know the pride in all of us that
that yeah it should be that there
shouldn't even be any discussions right
we shouldn't even have this conversation
so I think it is true I think we're all
we're all proud to be here we're all
pleased that we're here I think so many
people who are here but not everyone
came from something that they might have
been trying to escape but it is also
inescapable that this is originally the
land of the Quinnipiac people absolutely
we are here and need to honor those who
are here before us can you all join me
in thanking dr. Henderson
[Applause]
[Music]
you
[Music]